[Music]
jay starts off this hour in phoenix
arizona jay welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me sure how can i
help
um so i just wanted to know if we should
still be making um minimum payments to
our
navient loans if we think
that a settlement might
forgive those loans potentially
well that's a great question first of
all jay speak directly into your phone
for me just so we can hear you nice and
clear
so what are the what are the terms of
the settlement that you've heard so far
um
so the reason why i think it might apply
to us is the school that my wife went to
the art institute in minnesota they have
since closed
i mean they were part of a
justice department class action suit for
predatory um recruiting practices and
then obviously there's a little in mind
to see that the naviance
uh predatory you know lone
what have you so yeah uh we're hopeful
that that will you know
that will fall in line with that but you
know it's still saying that we have
minimum payments due
and my concern is some of the
stipulations that i i read into said
that um
some of the loans that would be forgiven
would be the ones that have
uh
that haven't been paid in the last like
seven months or something like that so
i'm like
make sure you making payments on these
or
well what happens if you don't make the
payment
i don't know
i don't like that i don't like that
option i mean if i'm in your shoes i'm
getting a lot of clarity about who this
is for if i'm going to get approved but
i'm not going to sit around for a year
not make payments or make minimum
payments i want this thing out of your
life
whether or not the settlement happens
and whether it applies to your situation
so yes i would continue making minimum
payments until you get more information
but in the meantime i mean you should
know the results of this pretty soon
right
it it says i will be notified by july
oh that is a long time
yeah here's my thing we do have other we
do have other debt that we're going to
pay down in the meantime it's just going
to rearrange our snowball a little bit
so like we could pay the caller that's a
lot of federal student loans that that
we can be paying what's the total amount
of your student loans
uh it has
sixteen thousand audience
and
25 000 is worth a sad
okay so the only ones that could be
forgiven are those navian ones right
yeah from that settlement and where does
that fall in your debt snowball
currently
uh it's our top two
okay so number three is our is our car
uh we owe about a little over 11 on that
so we were thinking of just throwing
everything at the car i suppose until we
figure out
see what shakes out in the next six
months
yeah so the car is your smallest deck
currently
uh no our um we have two
private navient loans um one is five one
is ten the car is eleven
well i mean if you want to go ahead and
attack the car that's fine what i don't
want is for this debt just to sit around
and we don't have a resolution and they
kick the can down the road and now it's
august october and you waited all this
time and they said no we're not going to
forgive the loans
and right if i'm you i just want to take
control i want to be done it's not a
major amount of debt if this was a
hundred thousand dollars that could be
forgiven i might say all right well
let's let's wait and see how this shakes
down
but
with your snowball and you guys
attacking this thing it's only gonna be
a few extra months right how much uh
what's your income household
uh we just got it up to about 150. heck
yeah
so with 150 how quickly you're going to
pay off all your debt total
uh
we could probably do it by the end of
this year but
my wife is uh in a wedding party in
hawaii so that might you know
that potentially is like another like
three months maybe attacked on to the
end whoa how expensive is this uh
situation going to be for her
uh
okay probably
uh we kind of budgeted it was like 3 500
ish so we're putting a couple hundred
bucks aside
okay well making 150 you guys should be
able to cash flow this and honestly you
could clean up the navian debt really
quickly and not have to wait and hope
for a settlement so that's what i would
do personally if i was in your shoes
if you want to start paying off the car
first
i mean that's fine but again i just
don't want this thing getting kicked
down the road and then you end up in the
same situation you were back at square
one
right but get the details i mean i would
i would get some real clarity if yes 100
chance this is going to be part of the
settlement and it will be paid in july
and my loans are a part of that get some
clarity on that because i do think it
could help the debt snowball and that's
what your question is is you know could
this help our situation if we just wait
and let this be forgiven
but right i just i have very little
faith in the forgiveness system and i
understand this is a settlement this was
predatory
and i hope that happens more because the
as you know there's so many scam
situations out there where colleges are
you know price gouging and hurting the
students out there and saddling them
with student loan debt and you guys
happen to be a victim of that so if i'm
you i just want to take control and i
don't want to put my future in someone
else's hands or even in a settlement's
hands and hope for that situation
right yeah but thanks for the call jay i
hope it works out for you guys i do hope
that you get this thing figured out this
is beyond just a general student loan
forgiveness thing
this is predatory colleges
this is scam colleges that promised one
thing and became another and they're
shutting down and a lot of people aren't
a lurch and you're you're one of those
people unfortunately you and your wife
but it's a great question and i just
always choose to be in the boat of
taking control
and making a hundred fifty thousand
dollars
i mean this is a blip in your life
paying off 16k whether it's forgiven or
not
so i just don't want you to be stuck in
paralysis mode going well should we i
guess we shouldn't make these payments i
guess we should move on to the other
debt follow the plan the plan works
every time you work it use the debt
snowball list your debts from smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rate and start to attack it and feel the
progress and feel the freedom as you
free up payment after payment